[Musique]
depuis quelques semaines les marchés
sont quelque peu affolée en alerte face
à une menace chinoise qui pourrait bien
causer un nouveau krach boursier de
grande ampleur on parle quand même d'un
scénario à la lehman brothers en 2008
evergrande comme son nom ne l'indiqué
pas est une entreprise immobilière
chinoise qui a cumulé quelques 300
milliards de dollars de dettes
c'est carrément l'entreprise immobilière
la plus endettée du monde elle a eu
recours à de nombreux emprunts pour
acheter depuis la fin des années 90
toujours plus de terrain et miser sur
une demande et une hausse des prix
soutenus en 2015 en pleine crise
financière l'entreprise continue à
emprunter pour éviter de s'écrouler et
accumule encore et encore de la dette
dernièrement le coc vider la fermeture
forcée de centres commerciaux qu'elle
gère lui assène un coup de plus fin 2020
les autorités chinoises se fâche tout
rouge et décide de limiter les emprunts
des entreprises endettées et freiner la
spéculation immobilière dans le pays
pris à la gorge le géant immobilier doit
maintenant rembourser sans pouvoir
continuer à emprunter ce qui vu le
montant de sa dette est loin d'être
évident sa faillite pourrait ainsi se
répercuter sur tous ceux qui détiennent
de la dette de l'entreprise en chine
bien sûr mais il ya également blackrock
hamoudi ou hsbc
evergrande n'est pas la seule entreprise
immobilière chinoise dans la galère
c'est le cas également de fantasia rien
à voir avec le dessin animé une autre
firme dans l'immobilier qui vient
d'annoncer qu'elle n'était pas en mesure
de rembourser sa dette
peu